DANA HAN-KLEIN: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google,
My name is Dana Han-Klein.
And today it's my pleasure to
welcome award-winning author
Wesley Chu.
WESLEY CHU: Hello.
[APPLAUSE]
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So
Wesley, take it away.
WESLEY CHU: Oh, that's it?
Not even an intro?
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Yeah, that's it, yes.
WESLEY CHU: Oh, all right.
How far we got so far?
We got my name is Wesley Chu.
I am the author best
known for the Tao series
by Angry Robot Books, starting
with "The Lives of Tao,"
"The Deaths of Tao," and
"The Rebirths of Tao."
And I had a new book
come out just 10 days
you go from Tor-Macmillan
called "Time Salvager."
So today I'm going to do a
quick reading, just five minutes
a book and do a quick
scheme from "Lives
of Tao" and a quick scene
from "Time Salvager II."
So here we go.
In "The Lives of Tao,"
my main character,
a guy named Roen Tan, has
been inhabited by an alien.
He doesn't know it yet.
So in this scene is the
first time they actually met.
And this scene is actually
very near and dear to me,
because this actually
happened to me in real life,
minus the alien part.
OK.
"It was well past 10:00 PM by
the time Roen left the office.
Heels dragging, he trudged
out of the building
toward the parking garage,
continued south on Wabash,
and crossed the street, hearing
the rumblings of the train
as it passed nearby.
Suddenly, his highly attuned
sense of self-preservation
began to let them know
that it wasn't happy.
Something didn't
feel right, and he
fidgeted, as his eyes darted
up and down this street.
It was deserted, except
for a homeless guy crossing
the intersection
toward his side,
and there was no one
behind him, either.
This part of the loop was
poorly lit and a little rougher
than the business district
just a few blocks north.
Then the homeless guy changed
directions and moved on
to an intercept course.
Roen sighed.
He had learned to always keep
a few dollar bills on him
to give ti beggars.
It was the easiest way
to get rid of them.
He handed a buck over before the
homeless guy even said a word.
'Here you go,' Roen said
hastily and tried to pass him.
'Thanks boss,'
homeless guy replied,
shifting to his left
to block Roen's path.
"Look, man, I'm hungry.
$1 ain't gonna buy much.
Let me get a few more for a
meal.' He stepped in really
close.
Roen could smell
the faint traces
of liquor in and the stale
aroma of unwashed clothing.
'Sorry,' Roen mumbled, and
tried to pass him again.
The homeless guy continued
to block his path
and gave him a hard shove.
'I'm just asking for a
couple bucks to eat.' Not one
for confrontation, Roen
turned into a side alley,
and he immediately
regretted his decision.
Allies were where
bad things happen,
and he just did the
exact thing that idiots
from 'Travel Guide to the
City' would tell him not to do.
It was a dead end.
Roen turned around and
faced the homeless guy,
slowly retreating.
'All right, how much
you need for a meal?'
Homeless guy grinned.
'Price just went up, boss.
You gone and hurt
my feelings.' Then,
he became a mugger as
he pulled out a knife.
'It's gonna cost you your
cash, your train pass,
that bag you're carrying--
oh, hell, everything you got.'
Roen felt the rising panic
climbing up his throat
as he stumbled backward.
How did he get himself
into these situations?
'Look,' he stammered, barely
getting the words out.
'Let's talk this over.
I can give you my money,
but this is my work bag.
I need the stuff in it.
I'll get in trouble.'
'You don't think
you're in trouble now?
This ain't no
negotiations, asshole.'
'Tell him he can have the
money, but you are keeping
your bag.' Roen looked confused.
'What did you say?'
'What's wrong with you, boss?
God, you're dumb.
Give me your stuff before I
stick you.' Roen retreated
until his back bumped
up against the dumpster,
and he began to hyperventilate.
'What kind of a
mugger uses a knife?
It is almost insulting.
Listen carefully.
There are some wine
bottles at your feet.
Pick them up.'
'Who is this?
What's going on?' Roen cried.
'Your feet.
Bottles.
Pick them up.' The
mugger advanced.
'I'm losing my patience
with you, Tubby.
You're gonna be a fat dead
man any minute.' Roen looked
at the ground and saw
several empty wine bottles.
He picked up one in each
hand, and he raised them
in front of him.
'Hold them by the
neck-- the neck,
the skinny part.' Roen
hastily switched his grip.
'Stay back!' he warned.
The mugger paid him no attention
and continued to advance.
He was no further than
a few feet away now.
'Break the bottles and wield
them in front of you.' For
a split second, Roen saw
an image of a black-armored
gladiator standing in an
arena holding two swords,
one held high over his head
and the other in front of his
chest.
Now, he didn't know what was
going on or who was talking,
but he was so
scared right now he
did whatever this voice said.
He took the two bottles, and
he smashed them together.
Thunk!
They didn't break.
'What the--?' Roen looked
down, and he tried it again.
Thunk!
The damn bottles wouldn't break.
'Oh, for the love of--"
Roen gritted his teeth,
and he tried once more.
Thunk!
They finally shattered
into two jagged shards,
and he waved them
in front of him
triumphantly, trying to imitate
that already-fading image
of the gladiator.
'Good.
Say something mean.'
'What?'
'Threaten him.'
'You give me all your
money!' Roen yelled.
'That is not what I meant.'
The mugger did a double take.
'What?
I'm robbing you!
You give me all your money!'
'Not anymore,' Roen cried.
'I'm robbing you.'
'You can't Rob. me.
That's not how it works.' The
mugger no longer seemed so sure
of himself and
retreated a few steps.
Now the two of them stood really
far apart, both harmlessly
waving their respective weapons.
Every time Roen advanced,
the mugger retreated.
And every time the
mugger moved forward,
Roen scampered backward.
They began swearing
at each other.
'Come on, you fat asshole!'
the mugger snarled.
'You're such a goddamn
jerk!' Roen yelled.
'Attack.' Roen's eyes
started around the alley.
'Is my brain trying
to get me killed?'
'Bullies are cowards.
Attack.' Nearly a minute
into their standoff,
after a lot of
bravado on both sides,
something in Roen snapped.
With a burst of
momentary courage
and a really
high-pitched squeal,
he swung the broken bottle
over his head, and he charged.
The mugger no longer
seemed so sure of himself
and finally fled.
Roen chased him
for about 20 feet
before the physical
exertion wore him out.
He stopped, and he
bent over panting.
'Let him go.
You did well.
Go home.'
'Who is this?' Roen
said in between gaps.
But by then, the
voice was silent."
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So that was a scene
from "The Lies of Tao."
And it actually happened
to me in real life.
I think I was like
25 at the time.
I was taking bartending
class, because that's
what you do when you're
25, take bartending class.
And some guy tried to rob me.
And one thing I learned
from this experience
is that wine bottles are
really, really hard to break.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't if you've ever
tried to break a wine
bottle on purpose-- if
you knock it off a shelf,
it will fucking break.
But if you go like this,
it takes a lot of effort.
And it's funny, because
another thing I learned
is I spent several years
learning Chinese straight sword
and broad sword.
I took martial arts
for a long time.
And it's one thing to get
really good at something
when you're like in
a nice, safe school.
And it's another
thing when the guy's
got a knife sticking at you,
and basically everything
goes out the window.
So I spent, whatever,
5, 10 years learning
how to use a sword, and
the one the time in my life
I get to stab somebody,
I do one of these.
[LAUGHTER]
So I don't know what
the lesson is, actually.
But the lesson is, if
you're gonna stab somebody,
make sure you put yourself
in a real situation
where you actually
might be able to.
So the next thing I'm
going to read for you
is a scene from my new
series, "Time Salvager."
So "Time Salvager"
came out July 7.
And I'm going to give you a
little bit of background on it.
"Time Salvager" is
about the future.
Humanity has colonized
the solar system.
And it's the 26th century, and
we're running out of resources.
So there are these time
travelers called chronmen
who go back in time to what
they call dead-end timeline,
say a moment before a
disaster or an explosion
or some kind of tragedy.
So these guys go
back in time, say,
right before a ship explodes.
And they grab the resources, the
technology, the power sources,
the relics, all these things.
And they jump out right as the
bad thing is about to happen.
And the reason why
they do this is
because the number-one rule
of time traveling is you
don't change the timeline.
So when the explosion
or disaster happens,
it covers their tracks,
and they are good to go.
The problem with this
job is they experience
the last terrible moments
of all the victims,
and they can't do
anything about it.
I got this idea-- I
was reading an article
about this South African
photojournalist named
Kevin Carter.
And he was involved
with a Sudan family.
He was taking pictures
and journaling
everything that was going on.
He took a very iconic
picture of this kid--
this is a really sad story,
sorry-- about this kid crawling
toward an aid station,
and there was this vulture
hopping behind him.
And at the time, Kevin took
the picture and was like,
it's my job to
journal everything,
not to get involved.
So he left the kid there.
And he won a Pulitzer
for that picture,
and then he committed
suicide 11 months later.
A few weeks later,
I was on Chantix
trying to quit smoking--
and great drug, by the way.
I probably shouldn't
have said that.
I'm sorry.
Is that a licensing thing now.
Chantix is awesome.
No, but so Chantix gives
you very lucid dreams.
At one point, I had a dream
that I was on the Titanic.
I was a time traveler
on the Titanic.
I went back to steal
the Hope Diamond,
because when you go to
Titanic, that's what you do.
You steal the Hope Diamond.
And during the time I was
there, I befriended all the crew
and the passengers, and I
knew they were all gonna die,
but it wasn't my
job to get involved.
So right as the ship
was sinking, I woke up.
And I'm not sure if I actually
ever got that Hope Diamond,
but I remember when I
woke up, I was like, this
is the best use of time travel.
Because everybody talks about
like if you go back in time,
you did you kill Hitler or do
you become like Biff Tannen?
Does anybody know
who Biff Tannen is?
AUDIENCE: It's "Back
to the Future," man.
WESLEY CHU: All right, see,
I just dated all of you guys.
I know how old you are now.
[LAUGHTER]
But so like do you
either kill Hitler, or do
you use this great sports
almanac and win a lot of money?
And my problem
with time traveling
in a lot of time travel stories
is they always change history.
And we all know about
the butterfly effect.
But my thing is, let's say
somebody does end up time
traveling, and he kills Hitler.
What happens next?
For all we know, the Third Reich
could have happened anyway,
and instead of Hitler, who was
like all obsessed about St.
Petersburg, the new Third
Reich Fuhrer or whatever
looks at the map
and goes-- maybe he
read some Napoleonic
history and goes,
that's a lot of land to cover.
Maybe we shouldn't go east.
Let's go west instead.
So the number one rule
of time traveling is
don't mess with the future.
So the scene I'm going to
read for you is from the "Time
Traveler" series.
I will give you no context.
By the way, I only
have like one voice,
so if all my guys sound
the same, I'm sorry.
"'Are you sure you weren't sent
by the boys from the society
who gave Old Titus one tug of
his beard before he goes off
on his final Light
Burst?' Titus 2.3,
Grandeur of Dark Side Prime,
having lived 155 Venutian
years, was the oldest
man on all of Venus.
He was the foremost
inventor of his generation
and once considered the
second-brightest mind
of the century-- once meaning
he had just recently been bumped
down to third by some upstart
19-year-old girl named
Priestley.
That was fine with Titus.
He was tired of being the
smartest guy at every party
anyway.
The stranger blocking his path
to his honorary Light Burst
craned his head and looked
up at the Needle Shapes
rocket, scheduled to take
off in the next 10 minutes.
'I assure you, Grandeur, as
great of an honor as it is
being granted
Light Burst voyage,
flying into the sun is probably
one of the worst ways a person
could die.'
'As soon as your
light shields--'
'I know what happens, boy!
I designed this
flaming contraption!
It's tradition here to send
these old ships off this way,
blaze of fucking
glory.' Titus huffed.
'I've taken four life
extensions already.
That's the record, by the way,
most granted any Venutian,
and frankly, my damn back's too
tired to hold me up anymore.
I've done more than
anyone in three lifetimes.
And if those jerk-offs want
to push me out now, well,
I don't have the
energy to argue.'
The two men stood at an
impasse on the platform,
even as the Light Burst
thrusters smoked and began
its pre-ignition sequence.
Titus really should
be buckled in by now.
Five kilometers
away, watching safely
in their observation tower,
his family, friends, and peers
were all waiting for
him to commit suicide.
'Your mind is as sharp as
ever, Titus,' said a stranger.
'Address me as Grandeur, boy.
I've earned this title.'
'I assure you,
Grandeur, I am here
to offer you an opportunity
to continue work.
If you do not believe
me, then by all means,
step into the Light
Burst and be on your way.
I won't stop you.
However, my scans have
confirmed that you
are still healthy and may
live for several more years.
If you wish you put
those to good use,
then you should come with me.'
Titus hesitated.
He had already said goodbye to
his husband and his two wives,
and he had held court
for his grandchildren
and played with this
great-grandchildren one
last time, making sure they
all realized that he wasn't
coming back from this voyage.
The boys at the society
had thrown him a nice party
and even given him a prostitute.
Everything fell pretty final.
Sometimes an old guy just had
to recognize when to hang it up.
Still, the opportunity
the stranger presented
was interesting.
After all, a few more years
was nothing to sneeze at.
But there was the
matter of tradition.
Isn't this what he was
supposed to do as an elder,
honored citizen of Venus?
What if word got out that he
skipped out on his own Light
Burst It would be a scandal.
'Excuse me, Grandeur, but
your time is running out.
The Light Burst is
scheduled to take off
in the next six minutes.
I need to be away
from the blast radius
when it takes off regardless.
You need to be on
that ship or with me.'
'Don't rush me,
boy!' Titus snapped.
'Do you know who I am?'
'Yes, Grandeur, you are--'
'I was being rhetorical.
This is a big decision to make.
I don't like being rushed.
Where are we going anyway?'
'A place that needs your
skill and intelligence,
a place where we can
continue to do good.
So can I assume you will come?'
'Assume all you want.
I'm still thinking.
How did you get past
security, anyway?
You know, I designed
this entire launch bay.
Call it professional
curiosity so in my next life
I can build a better system to
keep creepy assholes like you
out.
This is a private
party, after all.'
'Your two honor guards at the
door do not know that I am
here.'
'Really?
Guards, get your
lazy asses in here!'
The stranger sighed.
'I really wish you didn't do
that.' The two red honor guards
came running into the room,
both carrying their battery
tridents.
Their insect-like armor, more
ceremonial than functional,
were modeled after a type
of old Earth beetle that
used to be worshipped as a god.
The two men, however, were
elite warriors specifically
chosen to honor Titus
2.3's Light Burst.
'Stand aside, Grandeur,'
one of the guards said,
leveling his battery
trident at the stranger.
For a second, Titus feared
that the stranger would use him
as a human shield
and that he would
die at the base of his
own Light Burst ship
before even getting the chance
to kill himself properly.
That would have been
the final indignation.
To his pleasant surprise,
though, the stranger
did not stop Titus from waddling
off to the side of safety.
The honor guard that had spoken
aimed his battery trident
and fired a lightning
arc at the stranger.
The stranger tilted
his head just a couple
of centimeters to his left and
let the arch shoot harmlessly
past his head.
'You have really good
reflexes,' Titus observed,
admittedly entertained.
The second guard
charged in closer
and fired his trident as well.
Titus' chest puffed
up a little bit.
He recognized one
of his inventions.
It was a kinesis spear, one
of his latter inventions
that could wrap a kinetic
field around an object
and manipulate it.
He watched as the blue
field shot out and enveloped
the stranger.
Then, to his surprise,
nothing happened.
The field that was supposed
to surround the guy
just popped like a bubble.
'You must have a defective
spear,' Titus commented,
his face turning a little red.
Then his mouth dropped when
a strange, yellow crackle
of energy leaked
out of the stranger.
At first, it looked
like the battery trident
malfunctioned and was
causing some energy feedback.
Then Titus realized
that the stranger
was surrounded by this
nearly translucent field
of yellow light.
The kinesis spear exploded
in the honor guard's hand,
and the stranger seemed to have
somehow teleported or moved
really, really fast
next to the guard.
There was a clumsy
exchange of fists,
and then the honor
guard flew into the air
and slammed into the wall
on the far side of the silo.
The remaining guard fired again.
This time his lightning
arc hit the stranger square
in the chest.
But the blue arc
fragmented harmlessly
off the stranger's yellow field.
A similar yellow surge
followed, and an invisible force
struck the honor guard, cracking
his chest plate in half.
The impact slammed the guard
into one of the railings.
The stranger turned to Titus.
I'm sorry that hat
to happen, Grandeur.
If you do not wish to come
with me, I will not force you.
Titus, a lifelong
pacifist, harumphed.
'You young men, always thinking
with your dicks and biceps!
All right, now you
piqued my curiosity.
If I go with you, what's my
guarantee what you're offering
is true?'
'Would you like a cyanide
pill before we leave?
If you change your mind, you're
free to take the pill and still
commit suicide.' Titus look at
the Light Burst as it began its
final sequence, 60 seconds
before they were both burned
to a crisp.
It was too late to get away and
too late to get in the rocket.
It was kind of the story
of his life, always
taking too long
to make decisions.
'Oh, fine,' he grumbled. 'Though
I think it's too late.' In
a split second, the stranger
grabbed Titus and cradled him
close to his body.
Just as the rocket ignited,
the stranger and Titus
launched up the tube as if they
had their own invisible rocket
strapped to their asses.
They shot straight
through the launch opening
and cleared the planet.
A few minutes later in
the black depths of space,
Titus and the stranger
watched as a spark of light
erupted from Venus' surface,
leaving a thin, yellow trail.
They floated for
about 20 minutes,
watching his coffin
disappear into the sun.
'Like watching my own damn
funeral,' Titus grumbed.
'Now what?
Why are we still floating here?
It's making me dizzy, making
me want to shit my pants.
Where are we going
next?' He paused.
'How are you doing all this?'
The stranger smile
for the first time.
'Please stand by.
You will need to wait until
we are cleared to jump back.'
'Go figure.
You hurry me up, and
then you make me wait.
How ride.
What do you mean
jump back, anyway?'
'To the future.'
Titus wasn't surprised.
He had surmised as much
when the stranger wielded
all those strange powers.
'Holy hell.
I knew it.
Talk about burying the lead.
You know, boy, you should
have opened with that line.
I'd hop in your sack
right away instead
of beating around the bush.
By the way, do you frumps
from the future have the cures
for all my maladies?'
'Apologies, Grandeur.
There isn't a cure for old age.'
'Fuck,' Titus paused.
'Is the future nice at least,
like a utopian paradise?'
The stranger shook his head.
'I hate to disappoint you.'
'Fucking fuck.
I might as well have
stayed in the rocket then.'
'Would you like your cyanide
pill now or when get there?'"
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So that was my two readings.
Are there any questions, for
all you people in the audience?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I think
my biggest question to you
is what was the different
processes about writing
these books?
Because like James
from "Time Salvager"
seems this kind of
more mild, less--
I couldn't imagine him having
that exchange with like
a homeless person who's
trying to rob him,
as opposed to like 'The
Lives of Tao" where--
WESLEY CHU: I mean, I wrote "The
Lives of Tao" a long time ago.
I write it 7 years ago.
So I was in a different
place back then.
And it was because
my second book.
You always write
your first book,
and unless you're
super talented,
you'll usually trump
that book, because you
make all the mistakes
in that first book.
So then I wrote "Lives
of Tao," and at the time,
I was going though
like a midlife crisis.
Because everybody in their 20s
goes through a midlife crisis.
That's right before
you play "War Craft."
So when I was 16, I told my dad,
I'm going to be a writer, Dad.
I'm going to be an English
major just like you.
And my dad's an
English professor.
And at the time, he
was like, no, son.
Your life will suffer.
[LAUGHTER]
So I didn't.
I became a computer
science major.
I did the whole corporate
thing for a while.
And it was never my calling.
So I wrote "The Lives of
Tao" with that kind of space.
Because "Lives of Tao" is
kind of a late coming of age,
kind of a self-improvement
kind of story.
So it was a very
personal story for me.
I wrote the book.
Then I played three years
of Warcraft, as you do.
And then I sold it in 2011.
So then "Time Salvager"
is my fourth book.
And by then, I'm writing
more complex characters.
I'm adding a lot
more things to it.
So they're very different,
but I think they
both come from the same place.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Did
you find yourself
like maybe more rigidly
sticking to a writing schedule?
Or was it just kind of
like whenever inspiration
struck you'd write?
WESLEY CHU: Before you
get your first book deal,
you write when you can.
You work a job.
You go to the gym.
Around like 8:00 to 10:00 you
go and you write at a cafe.
I live in Chicago.
And I used to go from
like cafe to cafe,
like just abusing the hell
out of those bottomless cup
of coffee policies.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: [INAUDIBLE].
WESLEY CHU: I went
full time last year.
And once you go full
time, I am contractually
obligated to be creative.
So inspiration be damned.
I mean, inspiration's great.
I would love to be inspired
every time I write.
But that's your job.
And sometimes you just
got to muscle through it.
And that's what
my new process it.
I worked corporate
for many years.
And when you work
corporate, you have
a lot of metrics you stand by.
So even with writing
now, everything for me
is based on metrics.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So
how much research
did you into the-- speaking of
"Time Salvagers," since that's
what I read most recently.
How much research did
you do into the time eras
that you had him jump into?
Was there a temptation
to kind of stick
to this fictionalized history
of events that happen past 2015?
Or were you like.
I really want to have him
go-- Nazi Germany is obviously
a kind go-to jump.
The Titanic you mentioned
was an inspiration.
Did you do a lot of
research on that?
Or were you just
like, he's going back.
WESLEY CHU: I did some
research on what he
was after in the Nazi period.
I mean, I'll be honest.
I just wanted to kill some
Nazis, because we all do.
But the majority
of "Time Salvager"
is actually where he
just jumps back in time
to moments after the present.
So I think I have two scenes
that are-- by timeline-wise,
they're realistic enough,
but besides that, I barely
jumped back into the past.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Right.
Did you did you that just
easier in terms of-- obviously
there's a lot of
technology that they
needed in the book that
hasn't been invented yet.
WESLEY CHU: Here's the thing.
I wanted to show
an arc of what's
happening to humanity
and the planet
without actually telling stuff.
So the way I showed
them was to have
them go to different
moments, important moment
in the future that was
the path of their present.
Does that make any sense?
All right, good.
So you should go back
there, and you kind of
get a broad picture of
humanity is doing really well,
and we're working together, and
then shit really bad happens.
And then we go to war
and then now we're
squabbling over resources.
And we already know what
happens in our past.
So I wanted to basically
paint a picture of what's
happening in our future that,
without actually saying,
all right, things are
really, really bad,
and this is why, I was
able to show them by having
his jumps go back there.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Right, by
having him kind of re-experience
these horrible things.
So if you personally
could go back to any era,
what would it be?
WESLEY CHU: Oh, man.
Can I bring a like a Gray's
Sports Almanac with me?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Sure.
You'd change the future, though.
I think you're violating your
own first time laws. [LAUGHS]
But if wanna go full "Back to
the Future II," like go for it.
WESLEY CHU: So "The Lives
of Tao" had a lot of history
in it.
I mean, these aliens have been
on the planet for a long time.
So I did a lot of
research from Genghis Khan
to like the 30 Years' War.
And basically no matter how bad
we think things are right now,
it's actually pretty damn good.
You go back there, you
get the Spanish flu,
we're drinking muddy water.
There's no sewer systems.
So I mean, I'm pretty happy
with the way things are.
And if I could change,
I would go through
and put a lot of money down
on the Patriots in like 2000.
[LAUGHTER]
Because at the end of the day,
it's all about fat stacks.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: [LAUGHS]
Sure, yes, yeah.
WESLEY CHU: So I'm very--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: As a player?
Yeah, it's the way
the world works.
WESLEY CHU: You either kill
Hitler, or you make money.
We can't kill Hitler, so we
might as well make money.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That's
very true. [LAUGHS]
WESLEY CHU: Sorry.
I'm like the worse like
technology inspiration.
Anyway, let's go on.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Well,
my next question
was going to be what technology
from the future would
you hope that's realized
in our lifetime,
aside from time travel?
WESLEY CHU: I guess I'd like
to colonize other planets.
That's the one thing,
especially more recently,
we got this awesome
footage of Pluto.
And did you know
Pluto was brown?
Yeah, I was like, Pluto's brown.
And I'd never think about that.
And then recently I've read
a lot of like Andy Weir's
"The Martian."
And we had that
thing a few years ago
where they were going
to colonize Mars.
That's a scam, right?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: They're
working on it, right?
WESLEY CHU: Are they really
actually working on it?
Anyways, I mean--
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
It's a slow process.
AUDIENCE: It's
still [INAUDIBLE].
WESLEY CHU: Is it still going?
Is it still going?
OK, I want to sign up for that.
But so the thing is like I am
all about colonizing something.
Now let's show our
Earth imperialism
and colonize a planet.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
The you'd sign up.
You'd sign up for that.
WESLEY CHU: Yeah,
I think I'd do it.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: All
right, the one-way ticket.
Your background
more-- do you feel--
like colonizing is a thing.
Colonizing is a thing?
Yes, that's the most
self-explanatory sentence ever.
[LAUGHS] I was gonna ask
about your background
and kind of the sense of--
you grew up in Taiwan, right?
WESLEY CHU: Yes.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
And so coming here
is probably-- it's
not a colony, but it
is a different
cultural experience.
And how has that kind of
played into your writing
and the experiences
that led to your books?
WESLEY CHU: I came
when I was five.
I grew up in Nebraska.
Back in Nebraska
in the '80s, there
was like five Asian
people in the state.
I think four of them
were in my family.
So I mean, I'm not gonna lie.
My Mandarin is terrible.
I have the listening
comprehension
of like a five-year-old.
I'm actually hoping my
dad never sees this.
[LAUGHTER]
My dad was the principal of
the [INAUDIBLE] Chinese school.
I think I flunked it.
So I'm very Americanized.
Obviously you always
experience things
when you look like one
of five people in a state
full of white people people.
But it's one of the things
you've got to learn to adapt.
And if anything,
because I had to learn
to adapt so early in
that kind of environment,
I have a lot thicker
skin about it
than I would say most
other minorities.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah, I come
from a family that is also
immigrants, and there is
that kind of sense of like,
but we're American.
But actually also for
me, I think, a big thing
was like the development
something like Taiwan has seen
and then going back to kind
of like the rural days.
And then there's this
kind of future Earth,
and it's just this kind of sad,
rural like reverse progression
of--
WESLEY CHU: You've
been to Taiwan, right?
Have you?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Not in
a long time, but it's--
WESLEY CHU: I mean, when I left.
I think it was
like '81, '82, all
I remember as a kid
was like big jungle.
And like I think I lost a dog
because he jumped in the river
and a bunch of leeches ate
him or something like that.
I could be actually wrong.
I'm probably wrong.
I was like four years
old when it happened.
But I went back recently,
and it's like really nice.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah, no,
that's what I'm saying.
It's just kind of like
seeing this culture build up.
And it's everywhere.
It's not just Taiwan.
WESLEY CHU: Is it everywhere?
Because--
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
It's not everywhere,
but a lot of places
are going through--
WESLEY CHU: Chicago's
train system sucks.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Have you ever tried
to take BART late at night here?
WESLEY CHU: I don't
know what that means.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: It's
out like L train.
WESLEY CHU: Does it suck?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah,
at night it does.
So I'll switch gears again.
What are some non-literary
influences for this book?
WESLEY CHU: The main
literary influence
would probably be Kevin
Carter, the photojournalist.
I mean, I read that article,
and it kind of blew my mind.
At the same time, I'm like, how
could you leave the kid there?
But at the same time, I kind of
got where he was coming from.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: It's a
little bit Prime Directive,
like from "Star Trek," where
it's like can't interfere
because like--
WESLEY CHU: I don't know why
I never though about that.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That's the first
thing I thought of. [LAUGHS]
WESLEY CHU: I'm the
biggest freaking Trekkie,
and I didn't even
think about that.
I'm a terrible Trekkie.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: It was
like Prime Directive met
like Sanderson's laws,
where everything kind of
has to have like an
equal ramification
and stuff like that.
WESLEY CHU: OK, now you're
taking it to another deep level
I am not ready for.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I'm sorry.
This is Google.
WESLEY CHU: You guys
aren't a bunch of geeks.
I always thought if the tech
world was like a high school,
Facebook would be
like the drama club.
All the geeks work at Yahoo.
You guys would be the cool kids.
You guys would be
the jocks, right?
That's kind of how I--
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Sure, I'll take it.
Yeah.
WESLEY CHU: Am I wrong?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah, I
don't know if any of us
were that-- some of us were
that growing up, but you know.
So what were some of your
literary influences then?
WESLEY CHU: When I was a
kid, I wrote a short story,
I think in like second grade.
And my dad read it.
And he's an English
teacher, so he read it.
And obviously it's a
stupid kid's story.
It was actually about
the solar system.
And he read it, and he was
like, son, this doesn't suck.
It's a very Asian thing to say.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I was gonna
say that's the highest
type of compliment
you would ever get.
WESLEY CHU: It's the
highest compliment
an Asian parent can give you.
And so actually took
me to a bookstore.
And he's like, buy
whatever you want.
I will buy you books.
And he basically like steered
me toward like "Beowulf"
or "Othello" or
some shit like that.
I love the classics.
[LAUGHTER]
But at the time, I
was in second grade.
So I ran to all the books
with all the pretty pictures.
And I'm going to say, I
don't know how this happened,
but I grabbed the Piers Anthony.
He wrote--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WESLEY CHU: No, no, no, no.
That would be his better series.
He wrote "A Spell for
Chameleon," which is
the first of his Xanth books.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, they're all
like planned [? words. ?]
WESLEY CHU: Yeah, and
that whole series gets
really weird as time went on.
But I think it got to 18 books.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That's
like "Wheel of Time"
bubbles of like--
WESLEY CHU: He's still alive.
He's got like 50 books, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WESLEY CHU: He's got like 48
books or something like that.
So he's still going at it.
So yeah, I was fed on a steady
diet of like L. Frank Baum
and like Piers Anthony
books as a kid.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Nice.
That's awesome.
What to you kind of
makes a good sci-fi book?
Just say, one I wrote. [LAUGHS]
WESLEY CHU: Let me
know when you find out.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, I'm a
relationship kind of guy.
Sci-fi is really broad.
I hung out with a friend of
mine, Remez Naam, who wrote
a great book called "Nexus."
And for him, he woke
a near-future sci-fi
about what happens
when-- in his book,
there's OS that you can
install in somebody's brain.
And that's like how
does that biotech
affect into your future?
And then you have somebody
like Ann Leckie, who
writes about these thousand-year
empires, and there's no gender.
There's gender but
there's no pronouns.
Everybody's a she.
So she's actually kind of--
there's so many things you
can do with sci-fi.
Personally, I like
the whole-- I like
to say that "Time
Salvager" is a love story.
And there is time traveling,
but time traveling is not
the main focus of the story.
I mean, I don't do paradoxes.
I don't do the whole
Groundhog Day or the "Back
to the Future" thing.
Time traveling is a tool
that I used to bring
these people together and to--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Right, it's
not the crux of the story.
They treat it as a tool.
Like companies in the future
treat as just like it's
a regular resource to them.
No, it definitely read as like--
WESLEY CHU: And obviously
every resource has rules.
I talk to a lot about
environmentalism in that book.
The socialist in me
comes out a little bit
when I talk about corporations.
So it's a combination
of those things.
And I would say time traveling
is the least important
of all of them.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: It read almost a
little bit as a cautionary tale
for me of like where
we could be headed,
where we want to kind of
avoid heading and like
the hopefulness of the people
in it trying to correct
the wrongs, like
eventually realizing, oh,
let's do something about it
instead of just letting this--
WESLEY CHU: People are
our ultimate resource.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
[LAUGHS] Exactly.
Well, so what are you
reading right now?
WESLEY CHU: I'm reading
Andy Weir's "The Martian."
I just finished Robert Jackson
Bennett's "City of Blades."
That book's not out yet.
It's awesome.
I just started "Armada"
by Ernest Cline.
That just came out.
And what was that fourth
book that I'm reading?
I switch between a
lot of books now.
So what was my last book?
I just finished
"Uprooted" nu Naomi Novik.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Oh, we
just did the talk with her.
WESLEY CHU: Oh, did you?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yes. [LAUGHS]
WESLEY CHU: Did it
go much better than
how this one is going?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: This
one is going great.
I don't understand that.
WESLEY CHU: All
right, all right, OK.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Well, OK, speaking
of "The Martian," "The Martian"
is being made into a movie.
"Time Salvager" is being made
into a movie, hopefully, yes.
It's on track to be.
Which character from
the book would you
play if you could
be in the film?
WESLEY CHU: Who
would I be if I was--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah, if you
could be one of the characters.
WESLEY CHU: I've done some
stunt work in the past.
And I was always like the guy
that gets beat up or killed.
So I'd be like
assault team number
five, gang banger number three.
I would run.
I'd shoot.
I'd get shot.
So I think I would just
be like a redshirt.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: OK.
An XO redshirt?
WESLEY CHU: Because if there
was something being made,
I would like somebody much
better than me to actually play
a role, play an important role.
I will be a throwaway character.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: You
made a great comment
earlier about being a
Phillips head screwdriver.
Can you talk more about that?
WESLEY CHU: I've been asked--
I'm a full-time writer,
so there's actually many
avenues that a writer can
do to make a living.
They can write novellas.
They can write
novels, short stories.
They can write articles.
Or they could actually do
screenplays or adaptations
and everything.
And I've been asked that before.
And I'm like, well, I am
a Phillips screwdriver.
I am a single-purpose machine.
I can only do one
thing really well.
It's OK-well, I guess.
I can do one thing in life.
That's the only
thing I want to do.
I don't want to
do anything else.
I've been asked
in the past to do
a pilot for "The Lives of Tao."
And I give it a shot.
And then I realized that
it's a different medium,
different skill set.
Back from my corporate
days, I am all
about subject-matter experts.
So instead of me trying to
play the different medium
and risk making
the product worse,
I'd rather not swallow my ego
and have somebody else do it.
So all I want to do in live
is write novels and stab
somebody once.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So if
you were hosting a dinner
and you could invite three
characters throughout history,
who would you invite?
They can be literary or real.
WESLEY CHU: I just want to
have drinks with like Hemingway
or like all those guys.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
That's fine, yeah.
WESLEY CHU: Because he
seems like a cool dude
to hang out with.
I like reading about
eccentric writers.
Because I never got
why they were eccentric
until I became a
writer and then I
started hanging out
with other writers.
And I can't tell if
it's because writers
are naturally
eccentric or writing
makes somebody eccentric.
So I read about all
these guys, and I
have a bunch of writer
friends, and I could kind of
see how their gears work.
And so I would like to hang
out with the really big guys
in the past and figure
out what makes them tick.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: If you could
go back in time 10 years
and give yourself some
advice, what would it be?
WESLEY CHU: You know what?
If you go back 15 years, I would
tell me to get over myself.
Back in your 20s,
as we all are, I
was very like insecure
and kind of a dick.
I probably drank too much.
So if I go back 15
years, I would probably
tell myself to chill out.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Good advice.
WESLEY CHU: And quit my job.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Also,
depending on the situation,
very good advice.
WESLEY CHU: And make that move.
Make that move out of Chicago
like you were supposed to.
Now you can't leave.
Sorry, that was a bit too much.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So to go back to your
Phillips screw head moment.
What would be some things
as a professional writer
you would give advice to
your first book as a writer?
Like what are some
steps you would
avoid at the very beginning
if you could go back in time,
I guess?
What fascinates me about
books is the journey of it.
It takes years.
It could take months.
I just don't know how you
came from your original idea,
then to your manuscript,
and then once you were done,
you're like, what do
I do with this now?
Like where are some
of the things you
did at the very beginning
that you know now is not
something you should do?
WESLEY CHU: Oh,
man, I mean, there's
no right way to write a book.
First time I did it, I just sat
down and I just did an outline,
and I just wrote.
And then 15,000
words in, I realized
that this is complete
garbage, and we
had to go back and
do it over again.
And then over time, I've develop
a process that's great for me.
I mean, there's no right
way to get the book done.
But I will say the
one common mistake
that a lot of
beginning writers make
is they start trying to
sell it before it's ready.
And when you refinish
your very first book,
we all think it's awesome.
We're like, hey,
I just gave birth,
and this thing is gonna rock on.
But chances are, it's not.
And the editing process--
when you write a book,
you made a piece of turd.
Now you've got to polish the
shit out of it until it shines.
And that's a really
long process,
especially if you're
writing your first book.
You need to edit it
many, many times.
You need to get as many
eyes as you can on it.
And I would honestly
say if you can,
if you can copy edit
yourself, great, fantastic.
If you can't, get a copy editor,
because that stuff really
matters, especially if
you're just starting out.
But yeah, there's
no real process.
You just gotta sit
down and write.
And you'll find your
own natural process.
AUDIENCE: If you have
the polished product,
if you could give advice to a
new writer, would you query?
What would be your next step?
WESLEY CHU: If you want to go
the traditional route, which
is what I do, I queried an
agent, and then I got a deal.
Actually, that's not true.
I lied.
So the way I got published
is a little bit weirder.
In 2011, my first
publisher, Angry Robot,
had a one-month open submission.
So for one month, anybody
can submit to them.
And at the time, 955 people
submitted books to them.
And then they went through
like an eight-month weeding-out
process.
It was like
Thunderdome publishing.
And then at the
very end, I think
25 people made it
to acquisitions,
and five people got deals.
So I was one of those five.
And by then, I gotten
an agent and go
on to your next
future book deals.
If you want, and it's a very
legitimate path to take,
you can self-publish,
Self-publishing is a big thing
now.
And if you don't want to
deal with that aspect,
and you're great at
marketing and being
your own little
business, then you
can definitely self-publish
and go down that route, too.
AUDIENCE: Like what's the best
typing instrument that you've
found, or software, whatever?
WESLEY CHU: I use a took
called Scrivener which is
a fantastic novel-writing tool.
It's am application
that you can use
that will help you organize
your entire process.
Like my first couple
books were on Word.
And Word's great, but once
you have 130,000 words there,
and then you've got to
make a change in something,
how are you going to
basically debug your novel?
And what Scrivener does is it
helps you organize everything.
You get multiple screens.
You have notes.
You can insert pictures
or whatever you need,
whatever it takes to help
you kind of like project
manage your book.
So that's the main tool I use.
There's another one that
helps with timelines
called Aeon Timeline.
It's supposed to be
a fantastic tool.
I don't know how to use it.
[LAUGHTER]
Whoever makes Aeon
Timeline, it's a great app.
You need better tutorials.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Do you
tend to outline your books
in a very detailed way first?
Or do you just kind of
give like story beats
and then go in and fill it in?
Or do you find yourself
going back later?
Or is it you have the idea to
start and then stick with it?
WESLEY CHU: I'm a
pretty high-concept guy.
So I'll get an idea first,
and then I get the characters.
And then I get the world.
And what I usually do is I'll
write two to three chapters
just to kind of get the
feel of the narrative,
get a feel of the characters.
And then once I kind
of have an idea,
once I'm confident that
this is a good idea
and I can go with it,
then I'll step back,
and I'll write an exhaustive
like 15,000 word outline.
And then 90% of the time, I will
jump the rails about 60% in.
So what I'm doing now is I write
an exhaustive up to about 70%.
Because 70% is kind of like
the tilting point for a novel.
The first 70%, you're
asking questions.
The last 30%, you're
answering questions.
And that's where a lot of
outlines get tripped up.
Because you're asking
questions, but sometimes you're
not always connecting
everything at that point.
So right now, I'll write
an exhaustive outline up
to 70% of the book.
And as I'm writing, I'm always
readjusting, readjusting
and adding notes.
I don't edit while I draft.
I highly recommend
not editing while you
draft, because if you do that,
you will be doing that forever.
So get that draft done first.
But as you're drafting,
leave little notes,
like a debug sheet.
And then once you've finish
the draft, then you go back
and you do your outline.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Who are some
of the people you turn to
or trust like as a
second set of eyes?
Or do you just kind of want
to get it all out first
and then send it to people?
Because I know like artists
and writers and anything that's
like your creative
baby, people are
very hesitant to
receive feedback on,
WESLEY CHU: Nobody
reads my first draft.
Nobody reads my third draft.
I think by the time I'm
in like my fourth draft,
my wife will read it.
And if she hates it, I
will just kill myself.
But then I have like a small
group of betas that I rely on.
The thing about betas is
you need to trust them.
You can't let some
dude off the street
who wants to read a book.
Because you don't know if his
opinion is any good or not.
So I have a very
small group of guys
that I trust that will
give me good feedback.
And once I get their input,
then I put their notes in,
and then it goes to my agent.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Do
you tend to send it
to people who are also kind of
involved in the literary world?
Or do you also include fans
or people who like reading?
WESLEY CHU: They're
all friends that I've
known for a long time.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That you trust,
like that they'd tell you
the truth about--
WESLEY CHU: I'm too
self-conscious to give
a draft to another author.
Because then they'll
find out I'm a fraud.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I
don't think that,
but like I get it's like showing
your work to any other person
in this world is always a
terrifying thing, be it code
or a book or a
picture you've taken.
So it's a very human thing.
WESLEY CHU: The whole
beta process also
is about self-confidence.
And once you get these people
that you trust, and they go,
hey, this book
doesn't suck-- that's
so my dad when I just
said that-- then I'm
ready to say after
a while, OK, I
know this book is a
solid piece of work.
I can show somebody that
I'm not as close with.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Thank you so
much for joining us today.
WESLEY CHU: All right,
guys, thanks for having me.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
Let's give him a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]